oui je pense qu'à pas les séries
néanmoins que je comprends ce que dit
françois mais je pense quand même que
c'est un petit peu plus complexe que ça
parce que si on prend aussi si on va sur
la brièveté pas par exemple qui voudrait
dire un grosso modo vous devez rester
attentif on a une heure d'attention papa
par jour pour amazon pour netflix
courage bio etc il faut absolument qu'on
le prenne et qu'on le cap et c'est nous
qui devons gagner cette économie de
l'attention bien sûr qu'à cela derrière
c'est évident on peut pas ne pas parler
de cette économie de l'attention elle
est partout autour de nous mais je pense
que focaliser cette économie de
l'attention seulement sur les séries
comme si elle était le grand coupable je
trouve que c'est un peu caricatural et
c'est nous ce n'est pas non plus les
maîtres en fait dans un grand tout si on
les met dans un grand tout de l'économie
de l'attention pourquoi pas néanmoins ça
n'empêche pas aussi cette brièveté il ya
des séries qui sont beaucoup plus
exigeants ce aussi que d'autres ça je le
comprends il peut y avoir une facilité à
allons vite à l'essentiel et sait il ya
aussi les séries qui sont plus
exigeantes que d'autres quand on prend
qui en a parlé the left over mais quand
on prend aussi de man in the right
castle qui tirait du bouquin de dit que
lui même qui a été l'auteur de blade
runner et qui a donné ce fameux blade
runner cinématographique enfin on peut
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain si
je puis dire il ya des scènes d'ailleurs
c'est une c'est une série qui est pas si
facile d'accès des scènes sont très
longues très sombre c'est une uchronie
ce qui n'est jamais non plus extrêmement
facile donc je pense que je comprends le
propos que vous défendez bien sûr
françois je peux y souscrire en partie
parce que je comprends bien de quoi nous
parlons à de la question capitalistique
de la question de l'économie de
l'attention de la consommation et non
plus de la culture et où ça je comprends
mille fois évidemment mais néanmoins
je trouve que c'est un peu aller vite en
besogne que ce texte notamment que vous
avez vous avez écrit qu il vraiment
jette un petit peu tour battures il met
un peu ou au même plan
[Musique]